Traduttore: Irene Andreoni
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
(Musica)
Io faccio l'educatore,
e il mondo degli educatori
è un po' particolare:
a volte ci piace stare lì a guardarci,
a dirci che abbiamo fatto un intervento
come doveva essere fatto,
che magari anche una parola
che abbiamo detto
abbiamo la presunzione che sia stata
un'illuminazione per qualcuno,
che riusciamo a cambiare
la vita di qualcuno
anche con una semplice parola,
con un gesto, con il modo in cui mi pongo.
Mi è capitata una cosa, un giorno:
ero seduto a tavola,
e mio figlio Zeno, aveva quattro anni,
dice "Io la minestra non la mangio".
E io: " Zeno, la minestra
la devi mangiare"
"No, la minestra
non la mangio, non la voglio"
"Zeno, la minestra ti fa bene,
c'è anche la verdura dentro"
"Appunto, non la voglio"
"Sì ma non si sente! C'è ma non si sente!
Mangiala, ti fa bene!
Zeno, devi mangiare altrimenti
non va bene: devi crescere"
"Io non la voglio".
"Va bene".
Al "va bene", Zeno prende il cucchiaio
e arrabbiato inizia
a mangiare la minestra.
"Zeno, perché stai mangiando la minestra?"
"Perché tu mi hai detto di mangiarla"
"Sì, ma tu mi hai detto che non la volevi"
Aveva capito tutto, io l'ho capito dopo.
Aveva capito tutto,
perché io avevo detto "Va bene",
ma non arrivava "Va bene".
Arrivava qualcos'altro.
Ci sono diversi approcci:
non ci si muove verso un problema,
verso una situazione,
verso un'altra persona
tutti alla stessa maniera,
mi sembra chiaro.
Ma se è così chiaro,
perché non lo facciamo?
Racconta la ricercatrice
Mary Helen Immordino Yang
che una volta una bambina
della classe seconda
della scuola primaria,
di fronte a un problema
apparentemente semplice -
"Una bambina di quelle" lei dice
"che solitamente dava
soddisfazioni alle insegnanti"
Il problema diceva:
"Si può parcheggiare
una macchina larga due metri
in un garage largo due metri e mezzo? "
La bambina, dopo aver pensato
per molto tempo a tutto questo,
ha risposto "No, perché se io parcheggio -
se quella persona, anzi,
parcheggia la macchina larga due metri
in un garage largo due metri e mezzo,
non può aprire la portiera."
La risposta è giusta o sbagliata?
Dipende.
La bambina non era legata
solamente al problema matematico:
"Due metri e mezzo; due metri; sì".
No. Ha probabilmente smontato il problema,
e l'ha ricostruito
tenendo conto delle sue conoscenze:
diremmo della sua cultura,
ma la usiamo troppo questa parola,
bisogna smettere.
Delle sue conoscenze,
delle sue esperienze,
di quello che aveva visto,
dei film, dei cartoni,
delle cose che aveva sentito
dei problemi che magari
aveva incontrato la sua famiglia,
qualcun'altro;
e la risposta era "No".
E infatti, giustamente,
l'insegnante prese
quella risposta come buona.
Poi c'è tutto il capitolo delle emozioni:
e questo complica moltissimo le cose:
perché oltre alle mie,
io sono influenzato dalle emozioni
di chi mi sta intorno,
dai percorsi mentali
di chi mi sta intorno.
Io vengo influenzato.
Le emozioni incidono
tantissimo sulle prestazioni.
ancora di più sulle relazioni.
Sono l'elemento che molto
spesso le determinano.
Tornando al discorso
"quando mi vuoi dire che una cosa va bene,
dimmi che va bene",
io spesso, per vedermi come genitore
nel mio lavoro educativo,
guardo i miei figli,
guardo Zeno e guardo Dora,
e cerco di capire in che modo
loro avviano le loro relazioni.
Perché il modo in cui loro avviano
le loro relazioni con le altre persone
siamo io e la loro mamma.
È chiarissimo.
È come se fosse disegnato lì davanti.
Quando io guardo come si muovono
nelle relazioni i miei figli,
io difficilmente sento
le parole che ho detto,
le belle frasi, le cose a effetto;
ma ci vedo il modo in cui l'ho detto,
la parte di emozione che ho usato
per caricare quelle frasi, quella bassa;
e non solamente
quando sono rivolte a loro,
ma sono rivolte un po' a tutti.
Ma a un certo punto,
facendo teatro da anni,
a un certo punto SBAM!
Incontro il clown,
incontro il mondo del clown.
Lo incontro a varie distanze,
alcune distanze più lunghe,
alcuni incontri sono più ravvicinati.
Incontro Slava Polunin, grandissimo;
incontro Paolo Nani,
incontro, molto più vicino, Andrè Casaca,
e gli altri clown del teatro Cart;
e ho l'occasione di vedere
i clown che lavorano con i bambini.
Ed è un qualcosa di meraviglioso.
Allora, piano piano,
ho iniziato a camminare da clown
nel mondo dell'educazione.
Non faccio il clown.
Non lo faccio, non faccio spettacoli:
ho iniziato a camminare come un clown
nel mondo degli educatori.
Ho visto delle cose meravigliose.
Ho visto dei risultati meravigliosi.
Ho visto dei bambini che mettevano,
sopra un palcoscenico di due metri per uno
un conflitto che magari
c'era stato qualche giorno prima.
E che non aveva avuto,
non dico una soluzione positiva,
ma almeno un progresso: era rimasto lì.
L'ho visto mettere in scena,
e trovare delle possibilità
che qualche giorno prima
non erano neanche
immaginabili o immaginate.
Probabilmente erano immaginabili,
ma non immaginate.
Ho visto bambini e bambine
che per vari motivi
non avevano mai parlato,
come sto facendo io, in classe;
ma li ho visti giganteggiare
dietro un naso rosso;
e li ho visti comunicare delle cose
che io mi sarei sognato.
E li hanno visti i loro compagni,
le loro compagne, le loro insegnanti.
E da quel momento
si è innescato un meccanismo
che ha fatto sì che dopo un po'
arrivassero anche le parole.
Ho visto dei risultati meravigliosi,
soprattutto quando ho capito
che quelli non erano risultati,
ma erano degli inizi.
Perché da lì partiva qualcos'altro.
Da questo, solitamente,
scaturisce una risata:
e va benissimo, la risata è fondamentale.
Non vi sto a parlare
di tutto quello che c'è
intorno agli studi sul ridere,
ma è una cosa incredibile.
Nel clown si lavora
tantissimo con il corpo.
Il corpo - che noia! - lo usiamo
per fare sempre le solite cose, sempre.
Quando si lavora sul clown,
a volte al corpo chiediamo di guidarci,
gli chiediamo che sia lui
a portarci da qualche parte,
vediamo fin dove può arrivare,
vediamo cosa succede
quando siamo in un posto
dove non poteva arrivare,
cosa succede, cosa scatta.
Lecoq, grandissimo pedagogo teatrale,
diceva "a volte il corpo sa delle cose
che il cervello ancora non sa".
È meraviglioso.
Ho iniziato a fare questo lavoro,
che ho chiamato "la pedagogia clown"
ma non ho inventato niente, nulla;
è che ho fatto una cosa
che per me è stata stupenda
e ho pensato che fosse
bella da raccontare,
perché magari è una cosa
che riguarda poche persone,
che riguarda quei due
bambini lì, quei cinque;
ma per loro, probabilmente,
è una cosa grandissima.
E a me interessa, mi va bene quello,
mi interessa quello.
Nella pedagogia clown, il lavoro
è quello di costruire insieme qualcosa.
Il lavoro è quello di sfuggire
da tutti i meccanismi dei pregiudizi.
Quando si fa il clown, si fa il clown.
I clown costruiscono insieme:
quello che uno propone,
l'altro lo accoglie, e così via.
Si fa questo lavoro tutti insieme.
Dopodiché, c'è il momento
in cui ognuno, col suo bel naso,
si mette sul palco, da solo;
e lì si fa un lavoro di mediazione
tra l'ascoltare e l'essere ascoltati.
Voi siete il pubblico -
fare il pubblico è più difficile
che fare l'attore -
lo facciamo, dobbiamo imparare,
io sono qui, sono solo;
ma io sono la persona
che in questo momento
raccoglie l'attenzione degli altri
che mi stanno guardando.
Poi cambiamo.
Ma ci dobbiamo educare
a questa mediazione.
Questa mediazione è fondamentale.
Tutto questo, alla fine, è un movimento
verso la pluralità delle possibilità.
Cercare di costruire
il maggior numero di possibilità:
Heinz von Foerster diceva.
"Questo è il mio imperativo etico:
creare situazioni in cui
il numero di possibilità si accresce,
deve crescere".
Perché quando si costruisce
insieme qualcosa,
ci prendiamo una responsabilità
e si fugge da quella
logica malata dell'obbedire,
e peggio ancora si fugge
da quella logica malata
del voler comandare.
Né obbedire, né comandare.
Il clown lavora sulle cose
che non si vedono.
Ci sono le cicatrici.
Le cicatrici si vedono,
e servono perché raccontano chi sono,
raccontano cosa ho fatto.
Luis Madeira scriveva:
"Amo l'ambivalenza poetica
di una cicatrice,
perché dice: qui sono stata ferita,
e qui sono guarita."
È importante: ma il clown lavora su altro,
quello che non si vede.
Abraham Wald era ungherese,
e fu chiamato, durante la Seconda
Guerra Mondiale, dal governo britannico.
Perché?
Perché troppi aerei britannici
venivano abbattuti
dalla contraerea, dagli altri aerei,
e allora fu chiamato per capire
dove andavano rinforzati gli aeroplani.
Ma gli aeroplani non si possono
rinforzare molto,
perché poi devono
essere agili, devono volare.
Allora Wald cominciò,
con i suoi collaboratori,
a esaminare i fori dei proiettili
di tutti gli aerei che rientravano,
Costruì una mappa a forma di aeroplano,
e iniziò a segnare di nero
i punti dove gli aerei
che rientravano venivano colpiti.
Alla fine aveva una mappa
dove si vedeva [i punti in cui]
tutti gli aerei erano stati colpiti.
Wald disse: "Rinforzate le parti bianche"
Come? Rinforzate le parti bianche?!
Certo, perché gli aerei che sono rientrati
sono stati colpiti,
ma probabilmente sono stati colpiti
in quei punti che non sono
necessari per volare.
Gli aerei che non sono rientrati
molto probabilmente sono stati colpiti
nelle parti bianche,
quelle che noi non vediamo.
Sono quelli i punti da rinforzare.
Sul clown si fa la stessa cosa.
L'approccio pedagogico clown
segue il ragionamento di Abraham Wald:
si lavora su quello che non si vede.
E per fare questo ti offro una protezione:
un piccolo naso rosso.
Perché è con un naso rosso
che puoi decidere chi sei,
puoi sperimentare, puoi cambiare idea,
puoi essere diverso
da quello che eri prima,
puoi essere diverso da quello
che vorrai essere dopo,
potrai rifare quello che hai già fatto.
Il naso rosso ti apre
e ti mette a disposizione di tutti:
ma è la più piccola
e la più potente difesa
che possiamo avere
contro qualsiasi attacco.
Grazie.
(Applausi)